miss malotte hundred I said I'm Malik
whom do you want to hear an incredible
story a wonderful story that touched my
heart and in sha allah i will touch
yours too I thought you would let's do
it he show now this incident happened
years after the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam had passed away it Ben
Amato the Aloha and another sahabi went
to go visit one of the mothers of the
believers you guessed it i sha they will
go learn from her as many others did
they will speak to her from behind a
curtain
she was an intellectual giant she was
one of the first female scholars in
Islam and eben Ahmad had asked her he
said I shall share with us one of the
most amazing things that you ever saw
the messenger of God do now upon hearing
the question I sure she paused and she
began to weep
now there's the weeping that someone
does when you bring up someone and then
they start to think of all the trauma
that this person brought into their
lives and then there's this kind of
weeping the weeping when you think about
a beloved in your life someone who
brought joy someone who brought peace
happiness in your life and that was the
prophet sallallahu alayhi wasalam when
she started to reflect and to think and
this is something that when you look at
all of the attacks that are brought upon
the last and final messenger problem and
peace invested be upon him if someone
was a victim of trauma in their life
they would not have helped to produce an
intellectual giant and Aisha was they
would not leave such an impact on her
that when she would think of him she
would begin to weep tears of joy
the story goes on and she said one night
he came so close to me until his skin
touched my skin and he said let me
worship my lord she said by God by Allah
I love it when you're close to me and I
love it when you worship your Lord now
let's stop and reflect over this for a
moment think about it she said I love it
when you worship your Lord for many of
you it's time to get married this is
half of your Deen and you don't want to
focus on just beauty that's it it's a
nice thing to have hum did a lot we're
all attracted to that we like that but
you don't put that at number one because
tomorrow the beauty will fade and then
if you didn't marry someone for the Dean
what are you gonna have you're gonna
have destruction you're not gonna have
someone who says I love it when you
worship your Lord she's gonna be lucky
when you bring home the money the dull
and she's making you work like a dog
she's making you bend over backwards to
get the latest car to get the nicest
house she don't care if you're in the
Masjid giving Dawa worshiping your Lord
no she's out there flaunting her beauty
to everybody no respect the man is hard
for him to give back that love because
he don't have but Allah had told the
woman to do and the prophets awesome had
had told us that this material world is
about possessions and material things
and the best thing of this world is a
righteous woman a woman who loves it
when you worship your Lord and if you
want to have peace in your home you want
to have a house full of blessings then
when the husband and wife when they both
worship their Lord she's not reminding
you the purpose of life she's not a
righteous wife you're gonna have issues
you're gonna have problems now for the
sisters let's take a minute and think
about what I said she said I love it
when you're close to me and I love it
when you worship your Lord
it's natural she loved it when the
prophet salallahu alayhi wasalam was
close to her like many of you do but she
knew that he had a greater
responsibility he took care of his
business as a man at home he would make
himself busy washing the dishes milking
the goat sowing his own clothes being in
the service of
this but then it was time for him to go
out and make a change in the world and
now you want to make sure that you're
also having a man you're not just
chasing a man for a good-look status
money someone who doesn't love to
worship his Lord
so same thing with the sisters make that
priority number one that it's time for
you to get married - and you need to
find the man who has what the best Dean
and the best luck and then when you are
married for those sisters that are I
know some of you would love to have your
husband maybe in your pocket in your
purse and the jealousy just takes over
at times relax you don't need to be
blowing them up every five minutes or 15
take a break when he's out there trust
in Allah don't worry you got a good man
who has took over law he's conscious of
his maker make the path easy for him to
get out there to do the Dawa to make a
change for the better
don't be a distraction don't get in the
way of him worshipping his Lord and this
is a way of ebody
this is a way that he's bringing those
good deeds by default when you make it
easy for him to do it you also get the
rewards so be like I sure was she loved
it when he was close to her but she also
loved it when he worshiped her Lord now
the story continues and I should tells
us that the Prophet SAW some had used a
water skin to make ablution water skin
is a leather pouch that has water in it
and she said he made ablution without
wasting any water whoa let's think about
that stop for a moment it could have
just said and he made evolution he made
wudu and he got up and prayed no I said
and he made evolution and he didn't
waste any water just think about this so
deep and profound maybe you go to the
Masjid to a Muslim convention and
there's water all over the place why all
you need to make will do water
conservation we have it indeed there's
maybe a cup of water that's it very
simple you don't need to come out from
the bathroom looking like you just took
a shower
there's no need not only you're wasting
water but you're making a mess all over
the place it doesn't
make sense so if we follow the Sunda we
use a little bit of water real real
basic thing you don't need to turn it
all the way up and it's hitting the sink
and it's splashing all over the place so
next time you're gonna make wudu you're
gonna get prepared to play it's very
simple turn it down water conservation
think of this is another part of the
Sunnah that you'll get rewarded for if
you implement it use very little water
and if you're using it in the sink
turn it down halfway so it doesn't hit
the sink and splash all over follow the
cinema the story continues and I should
tells us then the Prophet SAW some got
up and started to pray until his beard
became wet
that's not one tear or two tears or
three his beard became wet and I want
you to really think about that envision
that what kind of man when we looked to
his description this was a man they were
fighting for their lives and he'd be in
the battle defending people they'd be
hiding behind him he was like a lion but
then he'd be like a bashful virgin on
her wedding night and then in the night
he would get up and pray to his Lord
crying until his beard became wet and a
story continues and I should tells us
and then he prostrate it and the floor
became wet and then he turned on his
side he finished the prayer turned on
his side and continued to cry then bilal
radhi'allahu and came to alert the
prophet sallallaahu he was solemn about
the coming of the dawn prayer fudgin and
he saw that his eyes were red from
crying and he has o Messenger of God o
Messenger of Allah why are you crying
why are you crying when Allah had
forgiven your past and future sins he
answered bulow and he said what's
stopping you from crying when this night
these verses were revealed to me and
whoever recites them and doesn't think
deeply over them will be ruined
I mean a shine apology
in in
only one he loved me lightly one
now think deeply this is the verbatim
Word of God and this is the messenger
the final messenger sent to man kind of
problem Hamid peace and blessings be
upon him and these verses are revealed
in this ayah so profound and deep a lot
of speaking saying truly in the creation
of the heavens and earth and in the
alternation of the night in the day are
signs for people who think deeply they
remember God while standing sitting or
lying down on their sides and it's what
he was doing he was remembering a lot
and then crying standing and then
prostrating and crying and then on his
side crying the ayah continues they
contemplate the creation of the heavens
and earth saying our Lord you didn't
create all of this for nothing
glory be to you save us from the
punishment of the fire our Lord
whomsoever you sent into the Hellfire is
indeed covered in shame and the
wrongdoers will never find anyone to
help them the next ayah continues
saying our Lord we've heard the call of
the one who calls us to faith to Iman
saying believe in your Lord he said so
we did believe our Lord forgive us
therefore our sins are false pardon us
from our shortcomings and take our souls
back to you in the company of the
righteous think about that for a moment
you got to be with the righteous in this
life you got to be with those who are
God conscious who have taqwa in this
life who are inviting you to good you
can't be in bad company in this life
inspect to be with the righteous in the
next life
they ask the man why do you keep doing
the things you're doing all these bad
things that your friends are doing he
said simply hey monkey-see monkey-do so
if you're seeing your friends doing bad
things you in the company of people who
are not inviting you to good things
they're only inviting you to to bad
things to promiscuity to immorality to
lying to deceiving to cheating you
around those type of people you're
either inviting them to the goodness or
they're inviting you to those things
that are displeasing
to the Creator to Allah and then you end
up with them on the day of judgment you
can't expect to be around those type of
people that just keep following their
desires and says you know what hey you
can do whatever you want to do you only
live once no you live twice you live in
this world and then you live in the next
life and you see the paradise Jenna or
jehanne them and you need righteous good
front company to help you to achieve
that and this ayah makes it so clear and
the ayah continues our Lord grant us
what you have promised us a lot as
promised Jenna to those who believe and
do righteous good deeds Jenna is a
guarantee for those who obey their Lord
those who worship their Lord alone
without any associates or partners and
strive and struggle in his cause to be
good to do good that Jenna is there
waiting are you gonna turn towards it or
turn away and the ayah continues what
you promised through your messengers
Jesus brought it Moses brought at
Abraham bada and a last and final
messenger prophet peace and blessings be
upon him he also brought it Islam
submission to the crater not the
creation
and save us from the humiliation on the
day of assembly the day of judgment for
you never break your word Allah keeps
his promise his word is true I hope we
got to benefit from this story it really
touched my heart that's what I wanted to
share it with you inshallah God willing
there was a great benefit in there and
this can help us as we should be doing
every day making a change for the better
no matter what we did yesterday today
tomorrow is a new day let's start with a
new beginning now what are we going to
strive for it's our decision it's our
choice we're either going to work hard
to achieve Jenna run towards the mercy
of Allah by obeying him by doing
everything that he told us to do and
stay away from everything that he told
us to stay away from and you'll get to
know that anything that he told us to
stay away from are things that are
harmful for us society and humanity and
anything that Allah had told us to do
it's good for ourselves for our soul for
our heart and for Humanity thank you
very much assalamualaikum - LA he will
better care
you